alors finalement on veut bien que
l'assurance ne peut pas d'arbre c6 v6
millions qu'elle ne pas rembourser plus
donc aujourd'hui à s'en prendre aux
gardes du corps qui luttent en boîte de
nuit avec la soeur voilà donc à
travailler avec la demande voir l'équipe
c'est ça la question c'est est-ce que
c'est la demande pas sa boîte ça ça va
jouer évidemment juridiquement parce que
c'est à la demande c'est kim qui est
coupable
si c'est pas la demande c'est ce pauvre
gars du corps qui doit gagner 1500 euros
par mois et on se retrouve avec une
dette sur trois générations et c'est la
sueur c'est l'assurance qui demande au
garde mais absolument
mais voilà on n'a jamais retrouvé les
les bijoux de cette pintade qui c'est
tout ce que je déteste c'est vrai mais
c'est pourquoi elle est connue c'est la
fin de la génération mais non ça n'a
rien à voir si la tâche du gie d'aller
vulgaire d'ailleurs redit dans un indice
à tourner les gens s'en foutent les
téléréalités on commence à en avoir
marre gardé son sens moi je plains les
enfants entre kanye west et kim
kardashian
ces deux têtes pleines d'eau même si lui
faire bonne musique en y venant lui
c'est de plus un musée lui la com mais
regardez ça elle est fatiguée porno sa
vie c'est ça c est ce qu il y avait ce
qu'une fille qui malgré tout intéressant
- dentier dans une télé réalité
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est le vide
bah oui oui merci ça qui veut ça c'est
l'époque à tort voilà l'un des
divertissements qui vient pas chercher
l'information qui va chercher un
divertissement elle tough que ce qui a
si ça ne plaît pas tu change de chaîne
au bout d'un moment voilà mais brillant
feu gars tu te fais jeu c'est horrible
ce que je dirai non il n'a pas fini tu
veux bien fait que tu te fais pas
maintenant
des bijoux à paris qui trimballe ses
indécence tout ça c'est vrai que c'est
quand même pavaner avec sur ces réseaux
sociaux avec le poster sa fin d'accord
mais il ya un moment quand on a des ddd
bac de ce prix là sur soi on a une
sécurité ont une sécurité qu'un peu plus
renforcé par un garde du corps qu'elle
envoie à protéger ses deux soeurs qui
s'emboîtent de nuances à bastia ça buzz
ce que tu dis ça court
est ce qu'ils les problèmes banon
t'avoir d'avoir une drogue et ce que je
dis c'est que elle prend plus de
précautions quand on quand on montre ce
qu'on a et il a valeur de ses bagues là
on prend on prend des prequels méritoire
et se faire voler gildas j'ai pas dit ça
est ce qu est ce qu est ce que quelqu'un
rachat des infos parce que vous savez
que d'abord on n'a jamais retrouvé moi
ce qui me paraît étonnant c'est que la
police entière française américaine
était sur le coup parce que c'était un
c'était une très mauvaise publicité pour
la france et pour les américains qui
viennent dépenser de l'argent en france
donc je peux pas croire que si la police
entière est sur le coup on est jamais
retrouver les bijoux en or il a été tué
à l'époque son retail le peut-être mais
dans les heures qui suivent le bresse
qu'ils ont retrouvé des voleurs mais
dans les heures qui suivent cette bague
l'as invendables donc les retailler ça
disparaît c'est peut-être quelqu'un dans
la rue à paris qu'un petit diam's sur
l'oreille ou d'une mais le pire c'est
qu'elle s'est fait attaquer par des
parle pas un absolu parce que c'était un
bang de vieux qui se sont dit on va la
suivre via les réseaux sociaux
en partant alors il lance aussi sonné
bien sûr c'est par là d un film ça se
fait pas ça a dû être très pénible pour
elle vous y allez évidemment d'accord ok
je charrie un peu et donnait trop
d'infos ouais mais en partant ils ont
fait tomber des billets ils ont oublié
des bracelets la chaudronne millions
donnés par terre c'est vraiment des
pinpins les mecs qu'ils ont fait est ce
qu'on revient vol se trimballe quoi mais
et la mer derrière spies
c'est un élevage ayem a droit d'aller au
restaurant de là
enfin écoutez moi j'ai connu question
est ce que est ce que toute la halle à
la théorie abandonné qui étaient sortis
comme quoi tout ça a été organisé par la
mère par la famille parce que derrière
la télé réalité reprenait comme elle
commença à moi marché la télé réalité
forcément ils ont tout filmé et ils ont
mis ça dans leur télé réalité chaque
jour est ce que cette sas et écarter
totalement cesser complètement ses
passes et pau d'ailleurs la police il se
serait rendu compte très très bien où il
aura eu raison des graves dans merde
alors ça c'est magali parce qu'alors on
est vraiment le coeur de sites de magali
non mais non je vous écoute je suis un
petit peu choqué tout ce que vous dites
depuis tout à l'heure mais bon ces
personnes kardashian dont 40 de paris a
lâché dessus c'est trop facile de dire
c'est bien fait pour elle c'est ça c'est
la facilité et vraiment je trouve ça
hallucinant de dire des trucs comme ça
vraiment enthousiaste on voit qu'elle
est habillée comme ça c'est son problème
le magazine belle et rare qu'on voit une
belle image pour mieux en le disant
est-ce que c'est un exemple pour ma
fille on est là gagner tu peux répondre
à la crise à tous les anciens exemple et
contrôler mes enfants je me dit écoute
elle a quel âge cette fille elle doit
avoir 30 ans ma fille à la 11 ans donc
elle sort pas déjà avec les seins à
l'air mais ça c'est moi moi de lui dire
et c'est pas le magasin est ce que c'est
un exemple on verra qu'il regarde c'est
et derrière ça kim kardashian pascal à
onze on prends ma guitare capitaux des
desserts je dis merci mr dassier
mécontent de mes parents contre leur
enfant durer au moins ma question quid à
tous les mardis à quelque chose que je
dirais pas elle va donc on a raison ça
donc on a raison et que vous jugez que
magali sais pas s'il sait la maniabilité
du ring à une gamme c'est pas facile ce
que fait rien pour nos films pornos bah
tu parles de films pornos là pour vous
parler d'un cambriolage après vous
partez vous dites c'est bien fait pour
elle après avignon va le faire des
bonnes affaires
et parce que ce sont là résume c'est ça
tout mais m'a gardé quand on la résine
c'est un film porno de l'indécence des
débats devant qu'elle a raté un
placement de produit et je pense qu'il
ya toujours une clientèle à gagner une
question reste à demain tapis de 11 ans
te dis maman [ __ ] j'aimerais de kim
kardashian tu es heureuse ou pas deux
mais je m'en fous
la question est donc c'est non merci
tu étais tu n'es pas d'accord descloix
on le savait ça j'en sais pas normal
qu'on a envie de ressembler à kardashian
avant de cinq ans si tu n'as pas envie
de se rouler on peut dire la poubelle en
janvier à vincennes
voilà qui va encore faire une idée c'est
que taipei toulouse le 25
non mais vous